c'est aussi sans doute une forme de
rupture je vous le disais en titre deux
mois après son divorce nicolas sarkozy a
donc rendu public aujourd'hui une
relation sa relation avec carla bruni ex
top model devenue chanteuse
le couple à cette affiche est face aux
photographes
le week-end dernier à disneyland paris
yassine ben jannet de frédéric basket
c'est un touriste qui a filmé la scène
avec son caméscope nicolas sarkozy
samedi à eurodisney avec l'ex top model
carla bruni une sortie aux allures de
romance des paparazzi étaient sur place
leurs photos seront publiées cette
semaine dans plusieurs magazines alors
ce ne sont pas des photos volées le
président est là dans la foule il sait
qu'il peut être reconnu à tout instant
car la vanille est au moins aussi connu
que lui donc donc voilà on se promène
pas dans un endroit comme ça si on veut
pas être connu ou si on veut pas être vu
ou retend quelqu'un lundi carla bruni
ancienne icône des podiums reconverti en
star de la musique
elles passent du sol aux audio avec le
président de la république
la chanteuse a confirmé cette relation à
ses amis et notamment au directeur du
magazine l'express qui a révélé
l'information
j'ai eu l'impression que finalement la
manière dont les choses allaient aller
vers le grand public vers son public
elle ne lui déplaisait pas forcément
même si sa réponse officielle c'est no
comment
la chanteuse est le président deux mois
après son divorce c'est le nouvel
épisode du roman feuilleton de nicolas
sarkozy un feuilleton très médiatisé
mais pour l'instant aucun commentaire de
l'elysée
nico